here's an apocryphal story that is very
instructive a young man comes to visit
Mozart and he says Mozart I want to
write Symphonies and Mozart says how old
are you and man 7 23 Mozart says you're
too young to write Symphonies he says
but Mozart you were writing Symphonies
when you were 10 years old Mo says yes
but I wasn't asking other people how to
do it the matter is that not everybody
can learn everything some people are way
the hell better and of course no matter
how hard you try they're always guy or
gal so what does any of us need to be
the very top the whole world it's
ridiculous if you like animated videos
like this check out media plug using the
link in my bio